我没有什么法律上的问题要咨询，
主要是感情上的，
然后呢，
我结婚七年了，
我没有小孩，
我先生今年38岁，
我34岁了，
然后我们在一个省会城市，
房子的话是他婚前买的，
我的房子因为这两年呃，
疫情的一些原因，
然后就卖掉了，
然后我们他那方面有一点问题，
然后我们已经一年没有那个生活了，
他的长相和身高都和我有很大的差距，
我其实很想问，
如果说已经是这种情况，
还可以走下去吗？
其实我很想分开，
但是他人很好，
那赚钱不多，
我大概年收入12~15左右吧，
然后他的话年收入大概在目前非常少，
大概可能在六七这样子，
但是他挣的每一分钱除了去供月供之外，
他都会，
嗯，
能给我的他都给我，
而且他对我很包容。
性格非常好，
情绪也很稳定，
你自己喜欢孩子吗？
想要孩子吗？
我有想要，
但是我知道他养不起他，
我说养不起，
还是说他那方面确实也有问题，
对那方面确实有问题，
我们已经一年多没有夫妻生活了啊，
对于这个事情他自己有什么改善的措施吗？
比如他积极主动的去穿白衣服的那个地方去查，
去问，
去改善自己的状况，
他是，
嗯，
我跟他说过，
他觉得没有问题，
然后我就很抗拒。
他觉得每个人情况不一样，
然后我现在就是他，
就是我现在已经到跟他有身体接触，
我都有反胃恶心的感觉，
就会很直接的推开他，
就是他人，
他当年为什么跟他走到一块，
是因为呃，
他对我真的非常好，
他身为一个就是我，
当时我有负债，
大概20多吧，
他二话不说就把他所有的钱全部拿来给我填掉，
现在了也没有说过任何的话，
你们之所以要卖掉那套房，
原因是什么？
肯定该是我自己买的房子，
然后因为工作啊等等的原因嘛，
然后又觉得供的特别辛苦，
然后就把它给卖掉了。
呃，
本来我们是每人有一套房子，
都是婚前买的，
然后每人有一台车，
不是这么看待这个问题的啊，
因为如果一个男生，
他比如说一年跟老婆都没有正常的亲密的关系，
如果说是他的身体的原因，
假设他能够积极的去面对，
他认为这件事情是自己的责任，
那我自己就要去调整我自己，
不管是去穿白衣服的地方也好，
是心理上的也好，
还是什么，
对吧，
需要怎么调理身体也好，
需要锻炼也好，
如果他是一种积极主动的心态的话，
我们还有个判。
头，
那如果他自己觉得理所当然，
那我就这样啊，
你就该接受我呀，
那这样不是挺好的吗？
那我认为这个是。
有很大问题的，
对，
但是我其实这两年一直有想跟他分开的打算，
但是又碍于其实他人品真的很好，
他没有跟我分过你我这个东西就包括对钱方面啊等等的，
都是非趁的一个人，
而且我没有任何的婆媳关系需要处理，
呃，
我们因为他母亲不在了，
然后他父亲再婚了，
我们几乎不需要去处理这点关系，
所以这一点就特别好，
但是我想过来问你一个问题啊。
嗯，
就你自己对于夫妻两口子的亲密关系这个事情是属于那种有正常需求，
还是属于那种也比较寡淡，
呃，
有正常的需求，
但是他这个情况就慢慢的会让自己比较寡淡吧，
其实我想分开，
但是我又觉得三四岁是不是一个让人很焦虑的年龄，
然后目前除了自己有一台车子之外，
名下已经没有任何的房产了，
就意味着我分开，
我需要重新开始一切的生活，
我觉得这个对我来说很下一个很大的挑战。
那你有多少存款呢？
十来个吧，
你把房子卖了，
你为什么现在才十来个存款？
因为房子亏了很多钱，
卖的时候这几年他的收入很一般，
然后他也有一部分的负债，
我就拿了一部分钱把他的负债给填了，
你给他还了多少钱，
还了十二三吧，
他为什么会有负债呢？
其实这些钱都是我俩一起用呢，
因为这几年收入骤降，
然后我们俩无论是房贷车贷跟都比较高，
所以才会产生了肩负债，
你俩都不是过日子的人，
你俩都没有小孩，
就你俩过日子，
而且你俩婚前还都有房产，
你俩都有正经工作，
你俩过成这样了，
你俩都不是过日子的人啊，
对，
因为中间他有那个就是出现就是大业的情况。
所以会导致负债有所增加，
那他现在名下就剩他婚前那套房吗？
是不是对吧？
他那套房一个月还还贷款还多少，
一个月贷款还将近4000块钱，
但是他领到时的工资也就是5000来块钱，
你这过的啥日子啊，
这七年呀，
霍霍掉自己婚前一套房，
然后呢，
这七年也没有攒下任何的家业，
对吧？
对，
所以我就想着是不是应该就是分开啊，
然后他的收入又和我相差这么多，
能力也一般，
然后目前也那方面也是这样一个情况，
那你俩现在要是分开的话，
等于是基本上约等于你净身出户呀，
你看你总共存款只有10万块钱，
你还得分他5万，
然后他还贷款还了七年的那个婚前的那个房子，
你可以要求他还贷款的部分以及相应的增值涨价部分给你一半，
嗯，
其他就没有了，
因为他名下没有存款，
为什么？
因为他的钱都给你了，
差不多是这样子吧，
就相当于其实跟他分开，
就相当于净身出户，
对，
就把自己名下的车子开走，
差不多也就这样，
现在你住的是他那套婚前的房产，
是不是对的，
房子也没有增值，
是不是没有，
所以你你想让龙飞律师帮你解决啥问题啊？
其实我很想知道像这种情况。
是不是应该分开吗？
我感觉你俩这日子真的你俩都不是什么过日子的人，
你俩绑在一起过的话，
没有那种日子蒸蒸日上，
红红火火，
越过越好的那种迹象，
你俩他婚前给你还了20万，
你婚后给他还了12万，
也算是打的比较平了啊，
嗯，
是的，
我所以我觉得我应该不算欠他什么，
包括房子装修，
买家具，
然后我也出了十来万吧，
你俩在一起感觉不知道你俩过的啥日子越过越差劲的感觉啊，
你你自己也得琢磨琢磨，
以后不管跟谁过日子，
这日子得有个有个盼头吧，
越过越好啊，
不能越过越差劲啊。
卧龙复图你俩真是，
反正如果这事啊回到你自己的身上，
第一你要是喜欢小孩，
想要小孩的话，
你就得抓紧，
因为怪这个人，
他这个衣关节儿有点问题嘛，
嗯，
然后也是属于那种摆烂的状态，
他也对自己的身体就不是很上心，
也不去积极的配合治疗啊改善啊什么的，
你俩这个真的是现在目前就是很纠结在这一点，
所以很想问一下你，
如果说是您这边的话，
你会怎么去决策这个事情，
我是现在自己有了小孩儿就明确的感觉。
我还是觉得还是喜欢小孩儿的，
还是想要小孩的，
就是我是想要的，
但是以他的能力是没有办法，
就是像养一直一样的，
我这话我感觉我这话正常人都能听明白啊，
你既然想要小孩，
你是是得找个身体健康的，
你既然想想要小孩，
是不是找个对吧，
能养得起孩子的，
你然想要小孩，
你是不是得找一个对象，
那方面关系得正常的吧，
是不是明白好吧，
谢谢啊。